while everyone was focusing on the
latest presidential horse race news over
the weekend steve bannon possibly going
to jail trump possibly declaring his
campaign biden's lackeys fighting over
who takes the reins when the big guy
drops while everyone was focusing on the
big headline news most people missed the
most disturbing
political news story to come up in a
very long time care of cdc director
rachelle wolenski
two little kids just came down with
monkey pox
we do have seen now two cases that have
occurred in children both of those
children are traced back to uh
individuals who come from the men who
have sex with men community the gay men
mend community
and so when we have seen those cases in
children they have generally been what i
call adjacent to the community most at
risk
i should also mention importantly those
children are doing well
doing well
the children are doing well the children
who for whatever reason are living with
promiscuous homosexual men according to
federal officials just came down with a
dangerous disease a disease that is by
the way especially dangerous for
children it's not super dangerous for
lots of other people
a disease that you pretty much only get
from having sexual contact with gay men
who go to orgies and the kids are doing
well
according to recent research in the new
england journal of medicine 95 of
monkeypox cases have been transmitted
through sexual activity 98 of infected
people are gay or bisexual
41 of them already have aids hiv not
full-blown aids necessarily the median
number of sex partners that the people
who are infected with monkey pox have
had in the prior three months is five
and a third of them are known to visit
orgies and bath houses
within the month of infection
according to our own federal government
99 percent of american monkey pox cases
involve men who have sex with men
some activist groups are trying to blur
this reality and they're claiming that
monkey pox is not a sexually transmitted
disease or they're claiming that it's
affecting all sorts of other people not
just one group in particular the data
just don't back that up not even close
remember when we were supposed to follow
the science until the science was
politically incorrect a sane society
would be demanding answers here
they would be
interrogating the men who gave the kids
this std
the sane society would be demanding the
closures of the gay sex clubs where the
virus spreads we just shut down the
world for two years over a cough a cough
that nothing was able to stop anyway no
matter how hard we tried to shut it down
now we can't shut down a few bath houses
for a little while to stop an entirely
preventable disease that now a couple of
kids have somehow
we can't even ask the obvious questions
that this bizarre and disturbing story
raises
that's no big deal no big deal the kids
are fine nothing to see here move along
move along
it's not a big deal what's the big deal
move along move along it's okay
everyone's doing fine everything's just
great do you
do things feel just fine and great to
you
when you hear a story like this
kids got this std that you pretty much
only get from gay orgies little kids got
it
and even the cdc is saying they got it
from these gay guys with without
answering any of the questions what
what's the relationship here what do you
mean household transmission how did
don't no it's okay never mind don't ask
any questions it's fine right now the
cdc the public health authorities are
trying to have it both ways they're
trying to scare everybody about monkey
pox and everyone's risk of getting
monkey pox but they can't get past the
scientific facts which is that virtually
everyone who's getting this is getting
it from promiscuous gay sex so then when
they say well actually even kids can get
monkey pucks the obvious next question
is how how did that happen oh never mind
don't ask that question just be afraid
of this virus the virus that only
essentially only affects this one very
niche
community now it's no big deal stop
asking questions especially stop asking
questions about the sexual revolution
this is something we've heard it's not
just homosexuals this is something we've
heard for 60 years now at every single
stage of the sexual revolution going all
the way back to the 60s even going back
further at every single stage people
will say oh what's the big deal
come on what's the big deal stop being
such a prude
you're aw man you're such a square no
it's not what's the big deal about
free love what's the big deal about
promiscuous sex what's the big deal
about the hookup culture what's the big
deal about
ubiquitous contraception and and then
abortion which followed shortly shortly
thereafter what's the big deal with
redefining marriage what's the big deal
with the transgender movement what's the
big deal if a guy wants to pretend to be
a woman what's the big deal with the guy
going into the girls locker room what's
the big deal with the guy taking the
trophies from the women what's the big
deal now with
transing two-year-olds
two-year-olds that's the story
stonewall which is an lgbt group
just posted over the weekend
all this new research and here's what
they said they said research suggests
that children as young as two
recognize their trans identity
yet many nurseries and schools teach a
binary understanding of pre-assigned
gender
lgbtq
inclusive and affirming education
is crucial for the well-being of all
young people
what's the big deal
this this would be
some of the big deal this would be part
of the transiting two-year-olds
is part of the big deal and it's not
just the libs who shrug their shoulders
and pretend oh what's the big deal it's
the squishes it's the squishy
conservatives even more than the
liberals who are the problem here the
liberals know that this stuff is a big
deal that's why they've been fighting so
hard for every aspect of the sexual
revolution took a lot of energy a lot of
resources a lot of time to get us to
this point in society and it was a
political agenda pushed
essentially
all exclusively by the left it was just
abetted and permitted by the squishy
conservatives who said oh it's not a big
deal never mind move along move along
nothing to see here
we all know
we all know
that it is wrong to trans the
two-year-olds we all know that right and
we all know that this research is bogus
but even if it were real even if a
two-year-old
could a two-year-old can barely speak
but if a two-year-old could come up with
some conception of gender identity as
divorced from biological sex and and a
sense of self that recognize that the
little boy is somehow a woman even if
all of that were true we all know it's
wrong and should not be encouraged
and it happened pretty fast didn't it
to go from
1960s free love kind of culture to
what you would call the gay rights
movement that took what about 20 years
or so then to go from the gay rights
movement to redefining marriage that
took about
i don't know 15 years maybe a little bit
more maybe that was like 20 years then
to go from gay marriage 2015 to
trans and kids that took about i don't
know five years if that and then to go
from trans and kids
including in elementary schools to
transiting the two-year-olds that took
like six months this is accelerating and
every step along the way people say oh
what a big is this a big deal come on
this is a trivial culture war issue
yeah it's a culture war issue but it
ain't trivial that's why the libs are
spending so much time on it
we all know
if anyone here has ever had a
two-year-old
and you you can picture
these predators these political
predators coming up and trying to trans
your little two-year-old you would
probably feel an instinct to violence
okay you know it's a big deal everybody
knows it's a big deal
where does this come from
where does it come from it comes from
the re the
reticence of squishes
to state plain truths because they don't
want to offend people and they don't
want to be politically incorrect i'm
glad you like that clip
we are so close we are so close to one
million views then i'll get my big gold
play button from youtube then i will put
that outside of my office to boast to mr
ben shapiro and then he will be very
very angry and then probably at that
point youtube will just nuke my whole
channel so it'll be a moot point but
bring me there baby let's do it let's
make it happen we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you